the movie starts on a rainy day in Soul
where the protagonist Park dong one his
wife Yan and their son Su Chan arrive at
the new building they're moving into
however their excitement is cut short by
a car that is blocking the entrance to
the building adding to their annoyance
the owner of the car Y Man Su takes his
time to come out and move it despite
dong Wan's scolding man Su feels he owes
no apology and believes dongwan should
say sorry instead for waking him up on a
Sunday once the car is finally moved
dong Wan's belongings can be brought
inside during the wait he meets some
neighbors like an elderly woman named
Miss and a single mom with her son Lee
sanghun who is cautioned not to talk to
strangers following this the family is
eager to settle into their new apartment
feeling proud of owning a residence of
their own the next day suchan makes an
interesting Discovery his marbles
consistently roll in the same direction
on the floor suggesting either a slanted
floor or a tilted building he then shows
this discovery to his parents who are
equally astonished by it before heading
to work d one considers joining a gym
but changes his mind upon discovering
that man sue is the coach unwilling to
train with someone rude he leaves after
casually asking about the possibility of
their building being tilted but man Su
hasn't noticed anything unusual at the
office Don one researches tilted
buildings and the neighborhood on the
internet in the meantime his co-workers
congratulate him on his new home but
Express concerns about the location it
is revealed that Don one's home sits
Upon A now ruined industrial complex and
a car waste plan Don one assures them
that those are things of the past and
the neighborhood is now eco-friendly
despite the worries Don one invites his
co-workers to visit his apartment and
boasts about its charm the following day
the family heads out to get their
picture taken but Don ju's mood sour
when he encounters man Su again it turns
out that while man Su occasionally helps
at his sister's gym his real job is in
photography after the photo session they
decide to treat themselves to a nice
dinner at a fancy restaurant knowing
that Donan has been drinking wine they
opt for a cab rather than risk him
driving to his frustration man Su who
also works as a part-time cab driver
ends up being their driver further
aggravating dong one the next day the
protagonist's co-workers try to buy him
a gift for his new house but he prefers
to take the money and choose something
himself he ends up splurging on an
expensive rocking chair which he refuses
to share with his son that night heavy
rainfall begins affecting the building's
Foundation causing cracks in the streets
and affecting the glass door's track in
the morning when manso sees a crack and
touches it the door shatters completely
the neighbors who witness the incident
demand manso to fix it emits the
building issues dongwan also notices
cracks on the floor and contacts the
municipal Council for assistance however
he learns that all residents must agree
on repairs before any action can be
taken although he attempts to gather his
neighbors for a discussion they end up
arguing over trivial matters during
dinner man sue advises his son ysun tea
to smoke on the roof to prevent
complaints from Neighbors but Su tan I
smoking at all the next day after work
dong one hosts a small housewarming
party with co-workers Kims hyen Han
yunju manager Y and on Hao Yun upon
arriving at the building they find man
Su attempting to cover the broken door
with plastic rap despite manu's Newfound
concern Don one decides to ignore him
and focuses on entertaining his
co-workers at home they enjoy each
other's company indulging in food drinks
and discussions about the real estate
market in the next scene hyen goes to
the bathroom and realizes that there is
a water issue in the building meanwhile
d one notices that manager young isn't
drinking because he has to drive to
remedy the situation and allow everyone
to enjoy the evening Don one calls man
sue to be their designated driver giving
manager Y young the freedom to drink Hao
Y young however is not thrilled by this
delay and expresses her eagerness to
leave when Don one catches her
whispering to manager Yung he realizes
that they are romantically involved
despite hayo yun's denial manager Yung
admits their love for each other leaving
Su high and heartbroken as he had a
crush on hayo Yung this Revelation leads
to hayo Yun leaving in an upset mood
with Yun following her out Manu offers
to take suun hyan and yunju home but Don
one is shocked by the exorbitant fair
and invites them to spend the night
instead the next morning while dong
Juan's wife Yi goes grocery shopping
with Su Chan she realizes she forgot her
trolley unable to reach her husband she
tells suchan to go back to retrieve it
at the same time when SU rushes out of
the building for an important
appointment he realizes he forgot his
bag he then returns to retrieve it and
finds a sleeping yunju hurriedly he hops
back to his cab only to discover the
driver talking on the phone causing
further delay as suchan reaches the
parking lot to get a trolley the ground
begins to shake revealing a sinkhole
beneath the building the building is
then partially swallowed underground
before stopping when the hole becomes
too narrow to continue consequently Su
Hy's cab along with another car falls
into the sink hole in a panic he
attempts to open the door to escape but
the ground shakes again causing the cab
to slide down and land on the building's
roof narrowly missing man Su the mini
earthquake causes the car to slide off
the roof once more landing on dong Wan's
floor dongan then helps YH high and
Escape through the car's window
following this they rush to the bedroom
to assist yunju who has been trapped
inside while moving furniture they are
startled by man sue landing on their
floor after the railing he tried to hold
on to brakes concerned about their
amilies mansu reassures dongan that he
saw suchan taking the elevator and
should be safe however mansu is worried
about his own son prompting the group to
go to man Sue's apartment in search of
su T arriving at the apartment the group
notices a pair of missing shoes leading
man sue to believe that soon te is safe
the missing shoes suggest he was out of
the building when the incident occurred
following the incident the group heads
to the roof in an attempt to use their
cell phones to call for help
unfortunately there's no signal and
shouting goes was unheard by people on
the streets it is at this moment that
they receive a response from suun T who
is trapped behind the debris the group
works together to clear the debris and
free him Su T having watched survival
shows on YouTube advises them to collect
supplies and find a way to Signal their
presence to let Rescuers know they are
alive meanwhile a rescue team is already
at work but the situation becomes even
more daunting as explosions occur around
the sinkhole attempts to send Rescuers
Down the sinkhole are hindered by the
constant ground shaking putting them in
danger due to the escalating hazards all
residents including Yi and S Hun's
mother who were out of the building at
the time of the incident are evacuated
on a bus back in the building D onean
apologizes to his co-workers for putting
them in danger by making them stay over
furthermore he is saddened to discover
that his cherished chair has broken
during the earthquake as night falls and
rain starts pouring down the group
lights up a fire to stay warm while
eating in the morning with the rain gone
Rescuers attempt to send a drone down
the sinkhole sadly it loses signal and
Falls onto the building's roof the
survivors are thrilled to find it and
start talking to it hoping it will
record their messages however a part of
the building's wall crumbles at that
moment and the roof tilts severely
everyone manages to secure themselves
except for Su hayan who is on the verge
of sliding off taking a risk yunju
climbs dodging rolling rocks and grabs a
wire which she throws to Su hayan with
the combined efforts of man Su and Dong
wand they pull the wire rescuing s hayen
in this intense moment as s haan's eyes
meet yunju they share a special
connection as if seeing each other for
the first time again suddenly the wire
accidentally loosens causing man Su to
fall into a pool of thick muddy water
the group manages to hold on to each
other but man Su starts drowning his son
soon T jumps in to rescue him but also
begins to struggle in the mud thankfully
Don one breaks a window in one of the
bedrooms allowing mud to flow inside and
bring both father and son with it while
the group helps man sue and
the Drone finally reactivates and flies
out of the hole delivering news of the
survivors to The Rescuers Y is relieved
to see her husband is fine but her worry
for her son persists s Hun's mother
shares the same concern in the meantime
The Rescuers recall Yi mentioning Su
Chan had her phone and they track it to
discover that the boy is somewhere in
the building soon after the TV newscast
spread the news of the newly found
survivors back in the apartment man Su
expresses gratitude to dong one for
saving him and his son meanwhile Su hyen
tries to comfort yunju who is
preoccupied with the thoughts of her
parents and their unawareness of her
survival to pass the time and lift
Spirits they take a selfie together Su
hayan is surprised by the Newfound
closeness he feels with yunju at this
moment soon after the group receives a
pleasant surprise The Rescuers have sent
down Supply packages using small
parachutes the packages include
flashlights food oxygen water batteries
towels and even a satellite phone with a
signal unexpectedly the phone starts
ringing and it's The Rescuers checking
on them Yi interjects into the
conversation urging her husband to look
for Su Chan who they thought have left
the building unbeknownst to them the boy
is inside one of the cars in the parking
lot the group Springs into action tying
a rope around Don one to lower him into
the elevator simultaneously as dongan
enters the elevator through the roof
hatch and The Rescuers start lowering a
crane into the hole complications arise
the upper half of the neighboring
building finally breaks and falls into
the hole blocking access to to the
survivors completely The Rescuers bring
back the crane rendering it useless due
to the blockage in the meantime dong
onean manages to push open the elevator
door and reach the parking lot but the
shaking causes the group to lose their
grip on the Rope however the parking lot
is now beginning to flood due to the
Rain suchan cries for his dad inside the
car due to which dongwan is able to spot
his son suddenly he spots sanghun coming
down a large pipe with the help of his
dad suchan attempts to exit the car to
follow him just then more debris Falls
blocking the pipe and trapping him
inside consequently dong Wan's leg is
injured by Fallen debris despite this he
pushes the Rocks aside and gets up too
concerned about his son to dwell on the
pain Don one eventually ends up clearing
away the debris and rescuing his son
after an emotional reunion and hug they
notice something in the numerous holes
in the ceiling it's misso who informs
them that sunun isn't doing well in fact
he's dead realizing that the water is
rapidly Rising on n's floor as well
dongwan is eager to Escape however the
elderly misso insists that they leave
without her before departing with his
son she cuts some of s Hun's hair and
wraps it asking dongan to give it to S
Hun's mother when they are rescued with
suchan secured on his back dongan climbs
up the pipe leading him to the outside
wall of the building carefully
navigating The Edge he calls out for his
friends who quickly come to their rescue
soon after everyone manages to return to
the roof there they discover that the
opening hole has been blocked and the
water is now submerging the entire
entire building it's only a matter of
time before they are Swept Away With It
In A desperate attempt to survive the
group gathers bottles and other floating
objects to create a makeshift raft
thankfully man Su arrives with a water
tank which they fondly nickname Yellow
Submarine due to its color everyone
climbs inside except for mansu who
decides to stay behind and sacrifice
himself to close the lid as the water
rises the building falls on top of the
tank pushing it downward however it
quickly slips away and starts ascending
only to become entangled in some wires
yunju notices the complication and asks
the group to shake the tank with her
their efforts manage to free the tank
but a steel beam pierces through its
wall allowing water to seep in pushing
the beam from inside the group faces
another challenge suddenly Manu appears
using the oxygen sent by The Rescuers he
pushes the tank from the outside helping
them get unstuck sing hyan then inserts
his arm through the hole left by the
beam to prevent water from flooding the
tank despite man Su attempts to join
them he can't swim fast enough just as
hope seems lost his foot gets entangled
with the wires from the tank dragging
men Sue upward with the rest of the team
as the tank reaches the surface they
discover a second hole that poses a new
threat fortunately mansu climbs on top
of the tank and opens the lid saving the
group once again just then The Rescuers
spot them on the cameras and quickly
bring the crane out again using it to
swiftly lift the tank out of the hole
after a highly emotional reunion with
his wife Don one fulfills his promise
and hands Sun Hun's mother the package
containing Sun Hun's hair fast forward
to several months later Manu danan and
Yan visits ying hayen and yunju who have
become a couple living together in a
trailer while staying near the river for
the night they plan to travel around in
the future taking advantage of the
flexibility of their movable home as
they share food and drinks the group is
momentarily alarmed by the sound of
explosions to their relief it turns out
to be fireworks and they enjoy a lovely
view of the peaceful
Countryside